my situation was a little bit different
because i felt like my label just wasn't
like i ain't believing what i had going
on at the time but it's all these little
me is coming out and they
they stream they're going crazy doing
everything they're supposed to be doing
i'm like well that's what we're supposed
to be doing with my [ __ ] for me and it's
like
y'all let these [ __ ] outrun me now
cause i can't even drop as much as i
used to drop it just was like a
frustration thing on my label well i do
feel like too man like kind of what got
you here was being able to drop freely
heat up the streets
um
you know it's crazy because i i was in
the studio
like four or five months ago with you in
24 and you guys were working on a joint
project and it was like well how does
this how's this going to come out
because of your label real [ __ ] right no
kizzy shout out to 24 hours but like
um i just saw you commented on snow the
products post she had said she posted
her recap yeah she was like no
management no distro no label
with and that's what i'm doing
maybe in 2022 that changes and you
commented no no
don't sign
keep going and you're somebody who's
been a part of the major label system
for what six seven years now when did
you first sign 2015. so yeah it's about
six years right
and you know you've shared your
frustrations with your label recently
earlier this year um
what what is it like
where do you think kind of the
disconnect is
for p and b rock
and being on a major label
it's the it's like labels is like still
like they catching up you feel me but
it's like they still kind of stuck in
that old stigma where it's like
it's like a
i don't want to put it in i don't know
how to say it's like
the deals were so shitty back then you
feel me and they still like try to
implement that [ __ ] now like we still in
those times and they'd be like bro we're
not we streaming now and [ __ ] like it
ain't i mean people ain't going to the
store and buying it no [ __ ] cds and
[ __ ] no more [ __ ] over but they still
got the bills kind of structure like
that you feel me and it's like why the
[ __ ] if y'all can catch up with the
money on the streets why the [ __ ] y'all
can't catch up with the deals you feel
me like that [ __ ] don't be making sense
to me and they'd be like
once you learn it as an artist
that should be like kind of like scary
for a label they'd be like damn that's
my [ __ ] asking too many questions
right like
we gonna figure it out there try to
start you out you know what i'm saying
but it's like artists are getting
smarter right and then we like look at
like the like i always look at someone
like russ and i feel like russ gives out
so much free game to artists
right just like i talked to
he i always anytime i think like
something like i can't get this [ __ ] i
don't know what the [ __ ] i hit that
[ __ ] like yo what you think about this
bro
he had really like give me the whole
paragraph bro like how i should do this
[ __ ] some of the [ __ ] i could agree with
somebody should be like i could take
that and i do
it do it your way yeah hell yeah but
that [ __ ] different he's smart bro i
feel like the labels hate rust cause
he'd be really [ __ ] holding their
feet over the [ __ ] fire
he popped his [ __ ] and it's all real
lawyers hate him because he's like yo if
you're giving your lawyer ten percent
they're hoeing you ain't real [ __ ]
that's your i feel that's like bro
when i finally got to know the business
because you like when you come into this
[ __ ] bro like i see it all the time like
you just having fun you just so like
you want everybody else to do your [ __ ]
cause you want for like i don't want i
don't want to have to be the
i don't want to have to be the [ __ ] to
be looking through these emails just
decipher if this [ __ ] the serious about
this feature right right right trying to
make music right now i don't want no no
and you will put that [ __ ] on everybody
like huh you do this
you get it you do this you feel me but
that [ __ ] be like
you got to know your business bro you
got to know what the [ __ ] going on you
got to know everything that's going on
with you this is your [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying at the end of the day like
it's cool to have people that
a team you need a team but you gotta
still be on your [ __ ]
you gotta know what the [ __ ] is coming
through these emails who personally you
gotta know the same people that this
person you don't wanna be just having
people make
connections through you but you're not
even meeting the people you know what
i'm saying right now everybody building
relationships with nobody you don't even
[ __ ] know these people
that should be different bro